JOE, IT IS TIME WE GIVE AMERICA
A HISTORY LESSON ABOUT YOU.
THAT IS COMING TONIGHT, BUT
FIRST, WE START WITH THE CARNAGE
IN CHICAGO, CHAOS IMPORTANT,
VIOLENT CRIME SURGING IN EVERY
MAJOR CITY IN AMERICA.
DEMOCRATIC MAYORS, DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS, THEY HAVE FAILED IN
THE MOST BASIC DUTIES.
AND THAT IS THE MOST BASIC
RESPONSIBILITY, TO MAINTAIN LAW
AND ORDER.
THEY HAVE FAILED HIM PEOPLE ARE
DYING AND BEING SHOT AS A
RESULT.
THEY HAVE FAILED TO KEEP THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD SAFE.
THEY HAVE FAILED TO PREVENT
VIOLENT CRIME AND AS A RESULT,
MEN, WOMEN AND CHILDREN ARE
DYING.
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS ARE DYING.
THE MAYORS ARE LITERALLY
TWIDDLING THEIR THUMBS AND
PLAYING POLITICS.
VOWING TO ARREST ANY FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENT THAT ARE
SENT TO THE CITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TAKING
ACTION.
TODAY IN A MAJOR PRESS
CONFERENCE, HE ANNOUNCED THE
EXPANSION OF WHAT IS CALLED
OPERATION LEGEND.
THAT IS A FEDERAL PROGRAM.
IT STARTED IN KANSAS CITY AND
WAS NAMED AFTER A 4-YEAR-OLD BOY
WHO WAS KILLED BY GUNFIRE WHILE
ASLEEP IN HIS OWN BED.
AND NOW MORE THAN 100 FEDERAL
OFFICERS TO CHICAGO, 35 TO
ALBUQUERQUE WITHOUT ANY PROBLEM
IN ORDER TO HELP TAKE VIOLENT
CRIMINALS OFF OF THE STREETS.
THE MAYORS AREN’T DOING IT AND
THE GOVERNORS ARE NOT DOING IT.
LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT.
SPEAK WITH THE CITIZENS OF
CHICAGO ARE CITIZENS OF AMERICA
AND THEY HAVE THE SAME RIGHT AS
OTHER AMERICAN TO LIVE
INSTANT SAFETY, DIGNITY AND PEAC
NO MOTHER SHOULD EVER HAVE TO
CRADLE HER DEAD CHILD IN HER
ARMS BECAUSE POLITICIANS REFUSED
TO DO WHAT IS NECESSARY TO
SECURE THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD AND TO
SECURE THEIR CITY.
EVERY AMERICAN, NO MATTER THEIR
INCOME, RACE, OR THEIR ZIP CODE,
SHOULD BE ABLE TO WALK THE CITY
STREETS FREE FROM VIOLENCE AND
FREE FROM FEAR.
FOR THIS REASON TODAY, I AM
ANNOUNCING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL IMMEDIATELY SEARCH
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO THE
CITY OF CHICAGO.
THE FBI, ATF, DEA, U.S. MARSHALS
SERVICE AND HOMELAND SECURITY
WILL TOGETHER BE SENDING
HUNDREDS OF SKILLED
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
CHICAGO TO HELP DRIVE DOWN
VIOLENT CRIME.
>> Sean: SAFETY, SECURITY IS
THE FOUNDATION FOR OUR GREAT
AMERICAN DREAM.
EVERY CHILD, NEIGHBORHOOD, CITY
DESERVES TO BE SAFE.
YOU CAN’T CLIMB THE LADDER OF
OPPORTUNITY WITHOUT SECURITY AND
SAFETY.
THIS PRESIDENT COMMITTED TO
MAKING SERIOUS PROGRESS ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY.
LET’S GO BACK TO HIS CONFERENCE
EARLIER TODAY.
MY VISION FOR AMERICAN CITIES
COULD NOT BE MORE DIFFERENT FROM
THE LAWLESSNESS BEING PUSHED BY
THE EXTREME RADICAL LEFT.
WHILE OTHERS WANT TO DEFUND,
DEFAME, AND ABOLISH THE POLICE,
I WANT TO SUPPORT AND HONOR OUR
GREAT POLICE.
WE WANT TO BUILD FACTORIES IN
BALTIMORE, NOT BEIJING.
WE WANT TO MAKE OUR PRODUCTS IN
CHICAGO, NOT SHANGHAI.
WE WANT THE AMERICAN DREAM FOR
AMERICAN CHILDREN, AND I WILL
FIGHT TO DELIVER THAT DREAM
EVERY OUNCE, EVERY SINGLE OUNCE
OF MY STRENGTH, I WILL BE
FIGHTING.
BUT OPPORTUNITY CANNOT THRIVE,
WHETHER VIOLENCE, PROSPERITY
CANNOT FLOURISH, WHERE THERE IS
BLOODSHED AND SECURITY CANNOT
EXIST.
WHERE THERE ARE VIOLENT
CRIMINALS WHO ARE ABLE TO MAIM
AND MURDER WITH IMPUNITY.
THAT IS WHAT OPERATION LEGEND IS
ALL ABOUT.
>> Sean: "OPERATION LEGEND" IS
A BEGINNING GREATLY NEEDED IN
ALL OF THESE CITIES.
100 AGENTS CANNOT SAVE AND
PROTECT THE CITIES.
THEY CAN’T, THEY CAN PROTECT
FEDERAL PROPERTY AND THEY CAN
HELP WITH INVESTIGATIONS AND
THEY CAN GET TO UNDERLYING
GROUPS THAT ARE IMPLEMENTING
THIS VIOLENCE, BUT UNLESS AND
UNTIL THESE RECKLESS,
IRRESPONSIBLE DEMOCRATIC MAYORS
AND GOVERNORS DO THEIR JOB
AND/OR ALLOW THE HELP THEY ARE
BEING OFFERED, THEY ARE ALLOWING
INNOCENT PEOPLE TO DIE.
THAT IS ALL ON THEM.
NEW YORK, CHICAGO, PHILLY,
BALTIMORE, YOU NAME THE CITY,
SEATTLE, PORTLAND, IT IS ALL ON
THEM, ESPECIALLY TRUE IN
CHICAGO.
SHOOTINGS UP 47% OVER LAST YEAR.
HOMICIDES UP BY A WHOPPING 51%.
70 SHOT LAST WEEKEND, 63 THE
WEEKEND BEFORE AND EVEN CHILDREN
DYING EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
THE VIOLENCE REACHES
CATASTROPHIC LEVELS.
BY THE WAY, LAST NIGHT WE
REPORTED ON THAT HORRIFIC MASS
SHOOTING IN THE SOUTH SIDE OF
CHICAGO.
15 PEOPLE SERIOUSLY WOUNDED
OUTSIDE OF A FUNERAL HOME IN
WHAT APPEARS TO BE A GUN RELATED
INCIDENT APPEARED AT LEAST 60
SHELL CASINGS RECOVERED FROM THE
SCENE.
CAUGHT ON CAMERA BY NEARBY
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM, TAKE A LOOK
LOOK.
[GUNSHOTS]
[SCREAMING]
>> Sean: MAYOR LIGHTWEIGHT
ISN’T DOING ANYTHING TO PROTECT
HER CITY.
MOMENTS LATER TWO WITNESSES IN A
WAR ZONE AS THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN CALLING THIS AND APPLAUDED
THE PRESIDENT’S PLAN, PLEASE
HELP US.
PLEASE SEND IN.
THE MAYOR AND THE GOVERNOR WON’T
LET HIM DO THAT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE WISH IT WOULD STOP.
AND THE NEED TO GO TO FEDERAL
TROOPS IN CHICAGO BECAUSE OF THE
VIOLENCE.
AND REALLY, IT IS THE SAME AS
PANDORA.
SO WE NEED MORE CALLOUTS,
FEDERAL TROOPS, BECAUSE
REALLY --
>> IT’S A WAR.
>> Sean: AS THIS DEVASTATING
SCENE UNFOLDING, SADLY,
CHICAGO’S MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT
WHO IS A LIGHTWEIGHT IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING PEOPLE, BUSY ON
TWITTER.
WHAT WAS SHE DOING?
BASHING PRESIDENT TRUMP UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES WILL I ALLOW
DONALD TRUMP’S TROOPS TO COME TO
CHICAGO AND TERRORIZE OUR
RESIDENTS.
SHE CLEARLY HATES THE PRESIDENT
MORE THAN SHE CARES ABOUT
INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN AND CHILDREN
IN HER CITY.
HE DIDN’T DO ANYTHING EITHER.
BARACK OBAMA’S PRESIDENT, BARELY
MENTIONED CHICAGO 1,000 SHOT,
AND BIDEN DID NOTHING.
AT THAT POINT WHAT WILL THESE
LIBERAL MAYORS AND GOVERNORS,
WHEN DO WE HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
FOR NOT PROTECTING INNOCENT
PEOPLE?
PEOPLE SHOT EVERY WEEK IN
CHICAGO AND A LOT OF THE CITIES.
SIX SMALL CHILDREN KILLED IN
JULY ALONE.
LAST NIGHT FROM A 3-YEAR-OLD
LITTLE GIRL WAS SHOT IN THE
HEAD, BUT THE MAYOR IS WORRIED
ABOUT TROOPS TERRORIZING HER
CITY.
REALLY?
NO, WHAT HAS SHE DONE TO STOP
THE VIOLENCE?
WHAT HAS SHE DONE TO SAVE LIVES?
LIGHTFOOT WHO IS A LIGHTWEIGHT
ON PROTECTING CITIZENS SEEMS
MORE WORRIED ABOUT POLITICS THAN
THE MEN, WOMEN AND CHILDREN THAT
SHE IS SUPPOSED TO PROTECT AND
SERVE.
IT IS A NATIONAL DISGRACE.
SHE IS NOT THE ONLY DEMOCRAT
PUTTING POLITICS BEFORE HUMAN
LIFE.
IN PORTLAND, WE SEE THE SAME
THING.
DEMOCRATS THERE, THE FEDERAL
AGENTS, WE TRIED TO PROTECT
FEDERAL BUILDINGS FROM BEING
BURNED TO THE GROUND.
THAT IS THEY ARE RIGHT AND THEIR
CHILD.
PORTLAND’S MAYOR CALLING THE
FEDERAL OFFICERS THEY ARE, THE
OFFICER IS NOT THE ANARCHIST OR
THE PEOPLE CAUSING THE VIOLENCE,
CALLING THE OFFICERS ON
AMERICAN.
OREGON’S STUPID GOVERNOR QUOTING
AN INSANE CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT
THEY WERE OBJECTING PEOPLE.
PELOSI, GET THIS, COMPARING
AGENTS LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS TO
PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO
PROTECT AND SERVE STORMTROOPERS.
CONGRESSMAN CLYBURN, THE
LEADERSHIP IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY REPORT --
REFERRING THEM TO GESTAPO,
MEANWHILE CONFUSED JOE BIDEN HAS
NOT SAID A
SINGLE POSITIVE WORD ABOUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE 99TH% SINCE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
HE ACCUSED FEDERAL AGENTS OF
"BRUTALLY ATTACKING PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS."
WE HAVE ALSO HEARD HIM SAY
POLICE HAVE BECOME THE ENEMY AND
HE SUPPORTS THE DEFUND EFFORT OR
AS HE CALLS IT WE WILL
REALLOCATE SOURCES.
HE LIKES OUTWARD BETTER.
LET’S BE CLEAR.
ANARCHIST, VANDALS, HAVE BEEN
WRITING NEARLY TWO STRAIGHT
MONTHS IN DOWNTOWN PORTLAND.
THEY BOMBED THE FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE TWICE.
THEY POSSIBLY COME A PERMANENTLY
BLINDED FEDERAL OFFICERS WITH
LASERS.
DOZENS OF BUILDINGS HAVE BEEN
VANDALIZED, LITTLE BLAZE.
THIS IS A SHUTDOWN.
PEOPLE DON’T FEEL SAFE.
THESE ARE NOT PEACEFUL PROTESTS,
JOE.
AND THIS IS A SMALL EXAMPLE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS FACING.
TAKE A LOOK.
[CHANTING LET’S GO HOME]
WAIT TILL YOU SEE ON THE GROUND
HIM PORTLAND AS WE SPEAK, MORE
THAN 50 STRAIGHT DAYS OF VIOLENT
DEMONSTRATIONS IN THE CITY
DOWNTOWN JURISTIC.
ACCORDING TO BIDEN FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS THE REAL
ENEMY.
SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING?
BIDEN DOESN’T HAVE A PLAN TO
STOP VIOLENCE, MAKE AMERICA
CITIES SAFER TO PROTECT INNOCENT
PEOPLE SO THEY JUST TRASH
DONALD TRUMP.
NOW TO THE .1 OF THE OLD
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FAVORITE
TACTICS.
HE IS NOW PLAYING THE RACE CARD.
I POINTED OUT AND I’VE DONE THIS
HISTORY SO MANY TIMES COME EVERY
TWO YEARS, FOR YEARS LIKE CLOCKW
REPUBLICANS, THEY ARE RACIST,
MISSILES AND -- THEY WANT DIRTY
AIR WATER.
THEY WANT GRANDMA AND GRANDPA TO
EAT DOG FOOD, CAT FOOD,
PAUL RYAN OR REPUBLICAN TRUMP
LOOK-ALIKE THROWS GRANNY OVER A
CLIFF IN A WHEELCHAIR.
TODAY BIDEN ACCUSING TRUMP, THE
PRESIDENT OF BEING THE FIRST
RACIST PRESIDENT IN HISTORY.
GET READY FOR HANNITY HISTORY
REAL LESSON IN A SECOND.
>> RACIST HAVE EXISTED AND TRIED
TO GET ELECTED BUT HE IS THE
FIRST ONE THAT HAS.
AND THE WAY HE PITS PEOPLE
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER, IT DIVIDES
THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THAT YOU ALL BACK IN
CHAINS, RIGHT.
NOW IT IS TIME FOR A KENNEDY
HISTORY LESSON.
FORGET THE FACT THAT DEMOCRATS
HAVE ACCUSED EVERY REPUBLICAN OF
BEING RACIST.
1998 RADIO IN MISSOURI, THE
2,000 JAMES BIRD AD, AL GORE
REPUBLICAN, WE DON’T WANT TO
COUNT YOU IN THOSE SENTENCES.
THEY WILL PUT YOU BACK IN CHAINS
PURE LET’S GO OVER THE FACTS
JOE BIDEN’S HISTORY.
IT WAS DONALD TRUMP, NOT JOE AND
NOT BARACK WHO PASSED CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
AND PRISON REFORM.
IT WAS DONALD TRUMP, IT WASN’T
JOE AND IT WAS NOT BARACK WHO
SIGNED OFF ON POLICE REFORM.
IT WAS DONALD TRUMP ALSO DOING
OPPORTUNITY ZONES, TARGETING
MOSTLY MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS TO
HELP, WELL, BUILD THE ECONOMIES
IN NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HAVE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND BY JOE AND BROCK.
IT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP, NOT JOE,
NOT BARACK WHO USHERED IN RECORD
LOW AFTER RECORD LOW AFTER
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS COME UP WOMEN
INTO WORKPLACE, AFRICAN-AMERICAN
YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT.
JOE AND BARACK, 13 MILLION MORE
FOOD STAMPS FROM 8 MILLION
POVERTY, AND THOSE SINCE THE
70s.
HAD A 51 YEAR LOW IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE, THE WORST
RECOVERY SINCE THE ’40s.
THAT IS THERE EIGHT YEARS OF
FAILURE.
BY THE WAY, THREE YEARS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DONE MORE FOR
MINORITIES IN THIS COUNTRY THAN
JOE BIDEN, NANCY PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER DID IN 125 YEARS.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU LOOK AT EMPLOYMENT, YOU
LOOK AT OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND
MOST IMPORTANT LINK, YOU LOOK AT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
YOU LOOK AT PRISON REFORM.
I’VE DONE THINGS THAT NOBODY
ELSE -- AND I SAY THIS AND I SAY
OPENLY AND I’M NOT ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO DISPUTE IT.
I’VE DONE MORE FOR BLACK
AMERICANS THAN ANYBODY WITH THE
POSSIBLE EXCEPTION OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
NOBODY HAS EVEN BEEN CLOSE.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA MOB, THE
BIGGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN IN ALL THINGS RADICAL,
EXTREME DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
WILL NEVER TELL YOU THAT.
SO YOU NEED TO ASK YOURSELF THE
QUESTION, WHAT WAS BIDEN DOING
DURING HIS 50 PLUS YEAR CAREER
IN THE SWAMP FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WHERE THE
MINORITIES?
HERE IS WHERE IT GETS
INTERESTING.
ALL TELL ALL YOUR DEMOCRATIC
FRIENDS, WE KNOW HE WAS CLOSE,
SO HIGHLY OF THE FORMER
KLANSMAN ROBERT KKK BYRD.
FORMER CLAN LEADER.
THE CLOSE FRIEND OF MINE AND A
MENTOR.
THAT MAN FILIBUSTERED THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT OF 1964,
LYNDON JOHNSON NEEDED 80% OF
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE TO GET PAST AND MOST
DEMOCRATS ARE OPPOSING IT.
DURING A SPEECH, JOE BIDEN 1973
PRAISED DEMOCRATS IN A TWO-PARTY
SYSTEM IN THE SOUTH THAT IS
CALLED, WELL I’M A GOOD FOR THAT
I WON’T USE THE WORD
APPEARED AROUND THE SAME TIME
BIDEN WAS WORKING WITH THE
SEGREGATIONISTS.
HE DIDN’T WANT IMMIGRATION AND
ACCORDING TO NBC NEWS, HE LED
THE CHARGE ON AN INITIATIVE TO
KEEP BLACK STUDENTS AWAY FROM
THE BLACK STUDENTS AWAY FROM
WHITE STUDENTS.
THAT IS HIS RECORD.
77, BIDEN WORRIED HIS CHILDREN,
HIS CHILDREN WOULD GROW UP IN
A "RACIAL JUNGLE.
IF IMMIGRATION IS NOT DONE IN AN
ORDERLY WAY, WHATEVER THE HELL
THAT MEANS.
1993, REFERRED TO INNER-CITY
YOUTH AS PREDATORS ON OUR
STREETS AS HE COAUTHORED THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE CRIME BILL THAT
RAMPED UP PRISON SENTENCES FOR
CRIMES TARGETING IN THE END
MINORITY AMERICANS.
IN 2006, TELLING A CROWD, WELL
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SLIGHT INDIAN
ACCENT TO WORK OUT AT 7-ELEVEN
OR DUNKIN’ DONUTS.
I’M NOT KIDDING, 2006, A STATE,
2007, HE SAID THIS ABOUT
BARACK OBAMA, THE FIRST, OKAY,
THE FIRST MAINSTREAM
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WHO IS
ARTICULATE, BRIGHT, CLEAN.
THAT STORY BUT FROM A MAN.
WOW.
LAST YEAR HE SAID FOR KIDS COULD
BE JUST AS BRIGHT AS WHITE KIDS.
AND RECENTLY, YOU AIN’T BLACK IF
YOU DON’T SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP.
JOE DECIDES THAT.
JOE BIDEN SHOULDN’T THROW STONES
FROM THAT GLASS HOUSE.
THAT MOB IN THE MEDIA WILL NEVER
TELL YOU, BETTER YET, STOP
SAYING RACIST THINGS ALTOGETHER.
JOE, TAKE A LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
WHEN IS ANYBODY IN THE MOB AND
THE MEDIA GOING TO ASK HIM ABOUT
ANY OF THESE THINGS?
THAT IS THE TRUTH.
THAT IS THEY HISTORY.
BY THE WAY, ACTUALLY KNOWS IF
JOE BIDEN CAN EVEN FORM A ANSWER